-Our first guest tonight
is an actor and director
you know from his work on "The
Office" and "A Quiet Place."
He stars in Tom Clancy's
"Jack Ryan,"
which begins streaming
its second season Friday
on Amazon Prime Video.
Let's take a look.
♪♪♪♪
[ Glass shatters ]
Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Please welcome back to the sho
our friend John Krasinski.
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
What a genuinely --
You look great.
-Thank you.
-But that was genuinely
a great clip.
-Well, it got a "wow."
-It got a "wow."
-I was laughing backstage.
-I don't often "wow" at a clip
So much running and rooftops
-I am fake exhausted.
-Yeah.
-You can't -- I think people i
action movies, it strikes me
that you got to be really good
at running fast
for super short distances.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-It is, yeah.
-I think you did
a great job there.
-Well, thank you very much
-Yeah.
-You actually have to pump
your arms faster.
-Yeah.
-Because the first movie I did
that had action,
I ran like I did.
And it was -- it looked like
a "Scooby-Doo" character.
I was like --
[ Laughter ]
And they were like,
"That's not exciting at all.
-But that's the right way
to run.
If You "Mission: Impossible"
down, you know, like,
nobody wants to see that.
-And thank you for saying,
"Mission: Impossible."
We all learned from Tom.
We learned how to run from Tom
-Tom is the greatest actio
runner of all time.
-For sure, yeah.
-Yeah.
And -- but this is --
I mean, some of that,
I'm assuming you did
some of your own stunts.
Like, that little slide
down the roof.
-Yeah, I did more of my ow
stunts than I should have.
It was one of those things where
I was like,
"Guys, I'm getting older.
I don't want to do it."
And the stunt guys were like
"No problem.
Maybe just give us one.
And I was like, "Of course."
And then like 17 later,
I was like, "Guys, guys!"
-What was the hardest stun
you had to do for this?
-Jumping from building
to building. No.
[ Laughter ]
For this one,
it wasn't actually a stunt
It was -- It was a Black Haw
taking off.
And we did this one take
where I get on a Black Haw
and then the Black Hawk take
off all in the same take,
which sounds super exciting,
and it was,
except for the pilot didn't care
whether I got my seatbelt
on or not.
-Oh!
-So I was like,
"I'll see you back there!"
And then I was like,
"Not yet, not yet!"
[ Laughter ]
He was just like, "Here we go!
And I was like,
"Nope, nope, nope, nope!"
So in the trailer, when yo
see me, like, out the door
really looking confident, five
seconds ago I was not confident.
I was terrified.
-You filmed some of in thi
in London?
-In London, yeah.
-And your wife Emily
is from England.
-She is.
-But you never --
[ Cheers and applause ]
So you obviously spent
a lot of time there
but never shot there before.
-No, never shot there.
And certainly never shot a
rooftop jumping scene in London,
which was phenomenal.
They also shut down Piccadilly
in London as well for us.
It was very exciting.
But I think my favorite part o
the day was going back
to my father-in-law 'cause
there's always a little part -
by the way, my father-in-law
is the greatest human ever
-That's very nice.
-And he's got the greatest -
Thank you, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And he's got
the greatest accent.
And he's so impassioned
about everything.
So he was like, "What you
getting up to today, Johnny?
And I was like, "Oh, you know,
I was, like, running on
some rooftops.
And then, like, a guy jumps into
the Thames."
And he was like, "Really?!
That's absolutely wonderful!
Good for you!
Fantastic, fantastic!"
And I was just like,
"Thank you so much."
[ Laughter ]
Had I known that's all it took
when I proposed to
your daughter.
-"That's the only reason
I did it."
-Yeah, exactly.
-"Everything else is a sham.
You just turned 40.
Congratulations.
-I did.
-Big birthday.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Big birthday.
-Thank you.
Thank you.
-And yet still running as fast
-A little slower now.
[ Laughter ]
-This is very sweet.
On social media, you made
a plea for a birthday --
If anybody had any interest in
giving you a birthday gift
you directed them
to a great organization.
I want to give you a chanc
to talk about it.
-Yes, I told them
to give me money.
-Yes.
-If you're a fan of mine,
you should give me money.
That's what I said.
But, no, it all went to
these incredible people
and an incredible organization
Family Reach, which is based
in Boston.
And they help financial
situations of families
who are going through the battle
of cancer.
So not only is cancer as bad a
everyone knows it is,
but the financial stress o
going through that
and being with kids
or any family members
that are going through it
is so difficult.
So we raised some money
to help them out.
-That's awesome.
What a nice gesture.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, it was great.
And it's still going on.
You can still donate.
Go to familyreach.org.
-Familyreach.org.